water is the most abundant liquid on the  planet and everyone's heard of h2o but  do they know what it means  do you know what waters made up on h2o  hydrogen and oxygen so we have hydrogen  and oxygen  hey Stewart h2o everyone knows the  formula for water h2o no clue oxygen  what are tonight like Jim alkoxy gin oh  I didn't have an answer  hydrogen times Terry nonsense how do you  think you could maybe draw a water  molecule if yeah yeah from out beautiful  I'm refreshed okay didn't get a level a  staff another two pots oak stood in one  pot honey it's a little hotter than it  seems they would see a water molecule I  can have a gun oh pretty great I love  you what am I like you and you know what  I'm what is made out of scientifically  speaking  no I don't want a molecule h2o uh-oh  HS and a no H to it what's the I stand  for oxygen you know together you guys  could be inventing Cartesian that could  be the next thing